Joseph gordon-levitt everyone he's so
cute so adorable I bet you eat but
only with the crusts cut off first
if that is luck speaking of crusty
I'll get to you in a second Sybil I am I
[Applause]
know
I know Martha Stewart thank you for
being here seriously and congratulations
on getting that tie soccer team out of
your vagina
and into your sweatshops that's where
they are now surprisingly Martha said
that prison food wasn't that bad just
you know as long as it was clean-shaven
so she loves attention to detail is she
laughing
I'm terrified of her no I honestly
Martha sir I'm a huge fan and my mom is
even bigger fat my mom has learned
everything from Martha Stewart about
cooking and cleaning and withholding
affection so close to my heart
Kevin Pollack is here such an amazing
actor most I know Kevin is like one of
the greatest Impressionists of all time
I'm a huge fan my favorite of his is he
does an amazing Robin Williams I just
wish you would finish it yeah okay guys
listen all I'm saying is that we've lost
a lot of greats to suicide recently and
it's time we lose some okay's civils
gorgeous I'm like honored to meet her
and and to her resume is insane like if
you look at it it's just like model
actor singer you name it she's it
I don't know any of these people Sybil
why am I here Oh
literally you have like no friends
it's truly so cool to be sharing the
stage with these badass women Cybill
Shepherd Martha Stewart Margaret Cho
I'm sorry Dahmer era I'm sorry
I thought that was dumb a rare I know
you sleepy potato
Tom I love you but how did you have a
stroke on both sides of your face
explain that I don't get it
Dennis Rodman first met Dennis just
earlier tonight when he tried to sell me
incense on the sidewalk
I don't want any okay
Edward Norton is here anybody and looks
to me like if a marionette became a boy
and then that boy became an asshole
right he was so hot in Fight Club right
when he was Brad Pitt that was not
now let's get to Bruges Bruce this is
honestly a real a big personal moment
for me to be here roasting my dead
cousins second favorite action star I
know you obviously as the star of every
DVD you kind of just find on the street
obviously you had an amazing action film
career until Jason Statham started
balding I'm just not familiar with
action movies I don't know I've never
seen a single one of your films
consensually like it's always what some
guy puts on while he's trying to finger
me on his roommates couch she was saying
maybe I didn't understand the fifth
element and it wasn't cuz I'm a dumb
girl but because it's hard to follow
that plot when you're fighting off a
roofie and there's a knuckle inside you
you know just be oh I loved this extense
though I loved in the ending when the
guy came in my eye and I didn't have to
watch the rest of it that was great
a lot of people don't know that Bruce is
a very talented musician because he
isn't Bruce has also been very active
with the make-a-wish Foundation which is
where they make sick kids meet you so
dying doesn't seem so terrible so Bruce
in all honesty thank you for having me
here you're really cool you're so hot
and and this is a special night you
really are it's a special night
obviously your families your daughters
must be so proud of their father Ashton
Kutcher thank you very much good night
[Applause]
[Music]